herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen video
leute ersten titel angesehen wir machen
heute ein video darüber acht mädchen an
jungs mögen und was jungs und mädchen
was ja gar nicht merken experten für
frauenangelegenheiten unser mittelfeld
zu viele frauen
und wir machen das heute so um
rauszufinden was mir wirklich den jungs
interessiert sagen mach sich jeweils
sachen von dem wir denken dass mädels
interessiert sagte anna kirche oder der
schulberg nutzer zukünftig okay ich
mache den anfang und ich betragen bei
mädchen auf jeden fall interessiert
irgendwie verdient und wenn ja durchaus
interessant auswahl geben weniger
intelligent gemacht werden ein video zu
fear einer dekade
[Applaus]
irgendwie ist da wir jetzt wird auch
geplant man rechne ich bei koblenz am
laufen lernen ich dich dann buch zum
thema ist immer schwierig wie zum
beispiel über meinen schatten springen
in führung
ich muss dazu sagen ich habe es schon im
juni lösen verhalten hat und die meinten
die art und weise wie ich rede hätte die
gestörte noch verloren aber dafür mit
wunderbarer erscheinung
du musst werden sein weg führt ihn
ordentlich kalorien
ich bin sehr ordentlich unglaublich
wichtig ist schrecklich wenn jemand zum
beispiel persönlich abholen sondern
einfach wir wollen genau in der wolke
oder das war einfach so in der spüle
staat überhaupt nicht gerne
ok wärmekraftwerk ich denke wäre china
humor ich zum beispiel mit maxxim toller
mensch macht wissen wir alle
trotzdem zeigt jetzt kandidiert und nein
also ich persönlich denke aber wenn ich
so mit leuten rede dann baue ich immer
möchten wir haben jede vernunft und
gegen jede menschlichkeit
ok medien auch lenken wird mal ganz
interessant
minecraft kaum hört sich das für dich
dass du verwertete beschreiben kann
wie wichtig ist die intime performance
ein mangel wie gut man voll
[Musik]
funktionieren entwickeln zum beispiel
sieben dinge von denen man sich gedacht
haben
das werden viele dinge bei jungs stehen
vielen christa weisser jahre
diese vernichtung persönlich